all right guys bang-bang I wanted to
bring Jason Williams back he is a good
friend of mine a partner at Morgan Creek
digital with me we've done a bunch of
stuff over the years together but Jason
also has an incredible background that
we'll get to in a second on the
healthcare space around operations and
logistics and so I thought that he could
shine light on a lot of the issues that
people are talking about around the
virus this is being recorded remotely so
there might be just a little bit of
audio issues so if that pops up
throughout the recording just stick with
us and we'll do our best to to kind of
keep going through the conversation but
Jason thanks for taking time to come do
this that's my pleasure it's my pleasure
let's just start one with your
background for those that didn't listen
to the first episode yeah so beyond my
operations experience which I'll get
into I actually was a licensed physician
assistant for you for those who don't
know what a PA is it's a dependent
practitioner that has the the scope and
capabilities of prescribing medication
instituting medical treatment doing
procedures and all of those are mandated
authorized and approved by an attending
physician so a physician assistant is a
really important part of a healthcare
team they were born out of out of
Vietnam and naval corpsman who once
returned from the war had no place in
the healthcare system to practice
so actually Duke University set up a
program to take these naval corpsman and
give them a bit of a bit more polish in
training and developed physician
assistants I believe that happened in
1974 so it's a relatively new discipline
or addition to the healthcare team but a
really important one so I graduated from
physician assistant school in 1998
started working in the emergency room
moonlighting was accepted to Yale into a
surgical residency program for physician
assistants was really interested in
orthopedic surgery but
participated as part of the trauma team
at Yale and treating patients who showed
up to the emergency department but
beyond that I practiced medicine for 15
years as a physician assistant
mostly ambulatory care primary care
urgent care and emergency medicine did a
little bit of orthopedic surgery too as
I built fast med so my statements on
Twitter or the the conversation we're
going to have today is is really steeped
in my medical practice of almost two
decades and building fast med which was
the nation's second largest urgent care
and primary care practice at that time
we were doing nearly 1.5 million patient
visits a year and if you put that in
context a major emergency department in
the United States may do 50 to 100,000
patient visits a year so 1.5 million
patient visits a year is pretty
extraordinary for practice so that
that's really kind of my experience in
perspective in health care got it you'll
be super humble but that urgent care
facility fast med you'd built into 120
locations and about half a billion
dollar exit at the end of it all yeah
that's correct we went from you know me
out of my dorm room at Yale to 1,400
employees 123 locations in multiple
states across the country about 400
primary care physicians emergency room
physicians and pas and nearly half a
billion dollar exit in 2015 got it
so one of the things that seems to
continue to come up in the whole kovat
19 conversation is this trade-off
between we can either let the economy
suffer or we can let the health care
system suffer or kind of collapse is a
word that you hear used a lot I don't
want to touch on the economic component
of it for right now I just want to focus
on the health care side and so maybe
walk us through if you're at an urgent
care facility if you're at a hospital if
you're at a primary care facility what
are the different things that go into
kind of the utilization of your services
and your facilities that you
in times of everything kind of going
well that somebody in a position of
leadership would be thinking through or
kind of measuring on a daily or weekly
basis it's a really great great question
I saw your tweet this morning around you
know how you fix the economy's get
people back to work which is really
interesting but this is a weird time and
never before have I ever seen a
situation where we had economic stress
or an economic collapse with social
distancing or physical distancing it
doesn't allow for us to get back to work
and so that moment typically excluded
healthcare so during periods of economic
distress economic collapse you would
find healthcare utilization would
increase and if you step back and just
think about that for a moment people
still get sick now you've got the stress
of unemployment or underemployment you
still have to pay your bills and you
start to get all these social anxiety
depression those things lowering your
immunity and healthcare utilization goes
up I'm oversimplifying it but that's
kind of how I think about it what you
have happening here though is so weird
and I'm at the tip of the spear
I own a number of health care buildings
that rent to health care establishments
and I started to get the calls from
those tenants saying our health care
census is dropping and we're worried
we're not going to be able to pay our
rent and I really took a moment to
reflect upon that because I've never
seen that before
and so how does that play out in
healthcare you have this happen
ancillary or ambulatory care is around
the periphery of a hospital so imagine
you have dentists eye doctors GI doctors
urologist primary care
ancillary services like laboratory
medicine radiography around the outside
actually utilizations going to drop
because during this time of physical
distancing or social distancing you've
got a bottleneck in the emergency
departments and again I'm starting to
see the census rise so you're seeing in
a major metropolitan areas where the
hospital emergency rooms are starting to
get slotted and they're starting to seek
Ovid 19:00 show up and then concomitant
health problems also show up and people
have to remember most I see use or
critical departments so they have
patients in them right it's not like we
had ventilators and beds just sitting
there waiting for Co vat19 to hit and we
could just start filling them they're
probably at 85 90 90 percent census
already then you have this this pandemic
occur and you have utilization go up at
the point of the hospital system or
emergency departments so you the the
healthcare establishment is there early
stressed it breaks pretty easily
it breaks pretty easily can't make more
doctors can't make more physical
facilities at the bottleneck but the
periphery gets really weird during this
this time where primary care offices
close or limit contact they cannot
protect their staff so they're not built
for that they're not built to provide
PPE or personal protective equipment at
the level they need to in these
peripheral establishments so they're
just closing and those Doc's are going
home you're not doing elective surgeries
in the hospital which is kind of like
lifeblood to the economics of the
hospital right so the emergency room is
a feeder and let's call it 80/20 20% if
not lower are really complicated
situations that need
admission etc 80% are handled and
discharged and then referred to the
ambulatory or periphery system that's
going to kind of go away and then the
lifeblood or the kind of elective stuff
is going to go away and then you don't
have the facilities the stockpiles to
actually treat the increased census and
it becomes a pretty desperate situation
pretty quickly I believe here in the
United States yeah so basically you're
talking about is you're almost
separating healthcare into two buckets
right one is the places that are going
to be still turned on and the places
that will be turned off due to this kind
of social distancing etc a lot of when
we think of healthcare we simply think
of the hospital right or emergency care
etc what we are describing with that
periphery all the elective stuff the
general checkups the you know
orthodontist all that kind of stuff
they're basically just completely
turning off and saying we can't protect
people or our staff and therefore we're
gonna shut down just like every other
non-essential businesses and so when
that happens you're saying that the
utilization of all that and obviously
the revenue in those but this goes to
zero essentially because they just shut
down like every other business in
America yeah I mean again I I have not
seen this and again I have 20 20 years
25 years experience in space I've never
seen this before but I do expect I do
expect that to happen where these
ancillary services shut down like even
our urgent care business if I was still
the CEO of fast med I would legitimately
be concerned that I may need to close
here's what would happen if you have a
Kovan 19 patient show up and I'm not
even able to test so as a health care
provider I'm not practicing anymore but
I would I would run through this
algorithm in my mind so patient shows up
with COFF high fever for a number of
days myalgias headache etc I test them
for influenza which I could
at Fastnet and RSV it comes back
negative so I assume they have coded 19
right they've got all these flu-like
symptoms they tested negative for for
influenza A B and RSV whatever I can
test for with rapid test those are
negative
I assume the patient has coded 19 and
now I have to isolate my staff because
they have an exposure I've just lost
those health care providers and I've
exposed patients in the waiting room etc
to potential kovat 19 as well so you're
you have to practice on what social
distancing there and and shut down if
you'd have to shut down or limit access
to too fast me they would almost have to
go all teleMed yeah and so when that
happens you know the analysis is pretty
simple if it goes to zero those
businesses just like every other
business they get in a really bad place
very quickly right they can't pay rent
they are obviously the employees are
either furloughed or laid off etc and so
you just get in a really bad economic
impact in the non essential healthcare
services but then when we switch to the
essential services so let's say the
hospital the emergency rooms etc they
are in some ways supposed to be able to
handle kind of an influx of patients
around this what I think in
conversations with you has been really
interesting is even inside the hospital
though you can break down kind of the
emergency room from what ends up being
the higher revenue or better revenue
services like the elective surgeries etc
so maybe talk a little bit about just
the economics of a hospital in general
and how they separate out kind of the
emergency room economics from the
remainder of the hospital services yeah
so most hospitals have a system of care
that they've instituted and that system
of care isn't just at the hospital so
hospitals grow for the most part by
opening up satellite hospitals or buying
practices so they'll go out and buy
primary care offices specialist
cardiologists you're all
and they'll have a network to feed the
game is to have patients come through
the emergency department potentially
need procedures or tests and then send
them to the hospital systems procedure
Asst testing facilities and then keep
that revenue inside the system right so
you create electronic medical records
that are not bi-directionally integrated
as a sticky moment for healthcare right
so you once you get into my system and
my system communicates with my
peripheral system that's how I keep you
inside my network does that make sense
yep
but once that breaks down right the
ancillary czar closing the peripheral
system can't can't stay open because of
social distancing in this pandemic now
all you have is the acute high medical
complexity patients that need the most
resources the hospital system can
provide but you're not driving revenue
the way you need to with these other
services and it really puts the hospital
in a very desperate position the other
thing that the hospital has an
obligation to do which it's not equipped
to is provide PPE to most if not all of
its staff inside the hospital I use this
example if you were to buy furniture
office furniture in the past you'd go to
a big box retailer like Office max I
don't even know if officemax is still in
business but you'd go to a big box
retailer like office max and you'd go in
and there'd be 500 different versions of
desks etc that you could buy and you'd
pick a desk but they had no inventory
really so they would deliver they would
deliver the desk to you but you couldn't
take it with you and this just-in-time
inventory or a low inventory system
America kind of got drunk
because we've had such robust supply
chains historically I think health care
did the same so they went to like
just-in-time inventory maybe keeping 15
to 30 days supply of things that were
critical but non-critical stuff they
would allow it to run out and just get
back I think they got caught in this
situation most if not all hospitals in
the United States got caught with this
supply chain just-in-time delivery
strategy and they don't have the
equipment that they need because they
always thought they could get it but now
they're realizing they can't and you've
got all this weird stuff happening about
reuse of like n95 masks and storing them
in paper bags and and putting a mask on
top of a mask I've even heard you know
you wear the n95 mask and put a surgical
mask over the top of it and then you
know use goggles or visors to protect
yourself and we know through the
information we got from China that they
were able to really limit or shut down
the the passing of kovat by using PPE
correctly and so I fear that our lack of
supplies here or that supply chain
breaking down will cause you know
transmission of the disease through the
most the most exposed people which are
or healthcare providers right now which
we can't afford to lose them yeah so
let's go back for a second to kind of
the revenue that you're talking about
one of the things that it strikes me is
basically you're seeing an explosion in
the hospitals of the low margin revenue
but you're seeing a complete zeroing out
of the high margin revenue for the
hospital right so it's almost like the
exact opposite of what you would want as
a business who would rather see an
explosion and high margin revenue and a
decrease in your low margin revenue but
that's not occurring and so does this
put hospitals in a area where they need
to start worrying about
whoa or their ability to actually
finance operations or most hospitals you
know pretty well capitalized and that's
not necessary concern as much as just
there's gonna be added stress here and
so they're going to make smart decisions
to kind of weather the storm and get
through this no it's actually worse it's
worse off than what you've you've
explained imagine these some of these
medical procedures the most critical
ones are our lost leaders so there's no
revenue on them or you lose money on
them because you're providing so much
acute care that you're not compensated
for it remember some some people don't
have insurance
so there's there's going to be
situations where there is no payment so
you have low margin or no margin
procedures that are very expensive very
capital intensive time intensive
procedurally intensive that are
dominating your time as as this virus
starts to ramp up and we're in that
ramped up cycle now the stress is going
to hit the hospitals in a big way you're
gonna see community-based hospitals
suffer the most right those that are
most resource challenged then you'll get
into the academic multi-site hospital
systems they'll be able to survive
longer but they're gonna need federal
federal aid very very quickly to to
continue to operate and I would expect
to see that happening soon really you
think that the federal government had to
step in with actual assistance to help
the hospitals and other healthcare
providers continue to operate Oh without
a doubt they're gonna need to supply
them with PPE we're gonna have to hit
the federal supplies for that the
hospitals will not be able to to
continue to get access to the volumes of
masks and gowns and Tyvek suits and
ventilators you keep hearing ventilators
but there's a lot of other
medical equipment around the periphery
that they're gonna need access to they
just won't be able to continue to spend
without reimbursement to keep up with
the volume got it and then in terms of
the actual like operational efficiency
of the hospital right you know you and I
have talked I've got a brother who's
doing a residency program as an
orthopedic surgeon and he's actually had
his team split in half half of them go
to work half of them go home and they
continue to rotate on a weekly basis
basically but they don't see each other
to try to prevent if at any point
there's an infection in the hospital
only half the staff is there so it's
almost like you're putting additional
stress on top of what we've already
talked about now at certain times or in
certain hospitals you only have half
your staff available to actually
operationalize and kind of run the
hospital it strikes me is that just
putting you know even more pressure on a
system and a situation that's already
kind of bleak at best yeah like I had
this conversation with my wife she's an
ICU nurse and you know your first
instinct is to like rush into battle and
I love that about health care providers
because the work that they do is so
noble they don't think like Oh some I'm
not saying they don't but some are not
thinking strategically here and I
haven't seen a division of labor like
you're describing yet but I've had a
fair number of discussions with Duke
University Medical School staff and some
emergency room physicians about looking
at their staffing schedules and actually
starting to look at risk who in their
groups have condiment and health
problems who are operating in age groups
that that exposed those providers to to
morbidity and mortality and when you
segment the patients in a hospital
system or emergency department into
you know a Cove at 19 moderate or high
risk environment and then all the rest
of the patients
maybe you deploy your resources in such
a way as to protect the health care
providers from the environment that
could put them at the most most risk I
would challenge the healthcare
establishment to start to think about
that because the next thing that you're
going to see is beyond the ancillary
establishment closing is a lack of
provider resources as they get
quarantined you're seeing emergency room
physicians contract Ovid and having to
be isolated and you know it's just scary
yeah what do you think about it looks
like the DoD and a number of kind of
military type leadership they're
starting to step in they've recently
along with the governor of New York
taken the Javits Center which is a big
conference hall basically and they're
starting to turn that into a health care
kind of stand up place right where
people can go and they can provide
health care services in a somewhat
makeshift model they're also looking at
taking over hospitals or I'm sorry
hotels and other types of facilities
just trying to expand the capacity or
for care and I was listening to the you
know the one general talk about you have
to think about everything from the air
pressure in the room to whether the
building has central air or not to how
do you get the actual supplies in there
the staff etc do you think that's a
sustainable thing is just to go get more
capacity or is that something that's
just gonna take too long and it may not
be effective you know I think it's
interesting to to run those mental
models but given if I was in a position
of deploying resources I think mass
units and and constructing hospitals
that are specifically set up mobile
medical centers you know these type
structures deployment of like
the Naval Medical ships to the coast I
think those are more immediate and more
that's where we should focus our
resources right now you know going in
and and renovating a hotel it sounds
interesting but I think it's just not
set up to deal with what what you'd need
to treat these type patients I think the
resources are better allocated in
setting up they'll mash type
military-type hospital settings and
operatories and I just I think that
makes more sense to me pop got it and so
then what do you think in terms of you
know if you're running one of these
hospitals or healthcare facilities like
what are the changes that you're making
on a daily basis you described kind of
how you would look at your staff and
bifurcate them based on risk are there
other things that you're doing on a day
to day basis to try to either one
mitigate that the stress that's being
put on the system or to specifically
around the co vid you know kind of
threat yeah I mean when you look at the
way an emergency department runs you
want to start to segment it into areas
that you can keep running so and you
look at it by acuity and diagnostic
complexity so first and foremost acuity
I would set up an emergency department
to segment away all of your low-risk
non-respiratory type illness and move it
to like an urgent care setting so the
hospital you physically divide your
emergency department up so that those
patients are being triaged away from
those patients who are presenting with
fever and respiratory type symptoms you
know and then focus your resources and
your personal protective equipment there
so as to eliminate transmission or slow
transmission in the hospital then you
have all of your kind of trauma cardiac
stroke you know the other stuff they
have to deal with
away from the the kind of respiratory
kovetz stuff that's how I would approach
it I would eliminate all elective
surgeries you know again that's just
because you only have so many resources
to deploy I would try to keep my
peripheral system open as best I could
so if I owned a bunch of primary care
offices in my health care system I would
direct PPE they're added staff and try
to keep them open but you know again I
think in the current environment where
you have lots of fragmentation and
private ownership these physician groups
are going to make the decision to close
if they're not connected to a hospital
system got it and I think that you just
hit on a little bit of it but people
forget that the health care system is
not some you know robotic thing
there's humans that are making these
decisions and there's humans that are
administering the care maybe let's start
with the actual health care workers
themselves they're human right they're
dealing with the same challenges and
stress that every other American is
dealing with in terms of there's a
financial crisis that's looming they may
actually be worried about certain things
outside of work etc and then you
compound that with the challenges and
stresses of work how does a health care
system think about how the psychological
aspect of the people who are actually
administering the care and times of
stress like this you know they're forced
to consider it pop I would take it all
the way back to just the basic elements
of of a simple primary care office to
make a simple primary care office work
you need receptionists medical
assistants radiography laboratory
specialists and some type of healthcare
provider whether it's a nurse
practitioner physician assistant or
medical doctor at any one of those
points each are facing the same stress
or different stress and let's just start
with
schools when you close schools these
some of these people are parents well
what do you do with your kids so now you
you're gonna either put them in daycare
or you have to stay home with them
so you're out of work just because
someone's got to take care of the kids
when they're being homeschooled you know
beyond that the resources for most of
these businesses aren't that robust so
you know given what I expect to have
happen a decrease in utilization around
the periphery because of social
distancing and physical distancing and
fear they're gonna be forced to close
and so it adds to unemployment the
stress that we're feeling economically
and then focuses all of that the
utilization that is there in health care
back to the hospital system yeah
and I guess that carries up to the
decision-makers themselves right how
much of this is what I'll call kind of
government type health care system so
there's more institutionalization versus
private health care systems where it's
literally hey we've got a CEO or a
leadership team and they're private
individuals or employees that are making
these decisions yeah so if you if you go
from the federal level you have federal
mandates coming through but the states
run their health care their health care
for the most part right each state has a
Medical Board that medical board
provides guidance and operating
standards and practice standards for the
for the for the providers in that state
hospital hospital systems for the most
part have business leaders that are
making the decisions and it's tricky you
know I think that they're put in a
position now where you have to think
about a crisis and doing whatever it
takes to to shore up the gaps
and that's at the expense of
profitability until you can't do that
anymore then you shut down I would
expect that most legitimate hospital
CEOs are making those decisions at the
same time they're turning to the Fed and
the state and saying we need disaster
relief we can't continue to go all out
in the support of our communities
without revenue I think that's where
they are the peripheral system breaks
down quicker the hospital system happens
more slowly the academic institutions
that have more revenue streams even
slower but I think they're all put under
the same stress yeah and then I guess
the last part is there's a lot of people
who are making decisions right now at
work in a professional capacity but then
also fortunately they're this kind of
looming financial crisis they're worried
about that as well if you go all the way
to kind of the services industries like
restaurants hotels etc you're seeing
people being laid off losing their jobs
having to worry about kind of making
rent or their next paycheck most people
would assume that the healthcare
industry at least that the higher levels
of leadership and people who work at a
hospital etc are somewhat immune to
those concerns around job security but
is one is that true and then too
do they also worry about kind of the
financial crisis and given that most of
these are high earning type roles is it
actually something where they may be a
bigger risk because they actually have
more investments on the table and
they're worried about kind of what's
happening on the personal portfolio side
as well you know it's funny that's a
really great question and and I learned
this lesson when I was 25 years old I
was working with orthopedic surgeon in
Fayetteville North Carolina and he
talked me about debt-to-income ratios
and he said Jason most physicians live
well beyond their means and they're just
a paycheck away from losing everything
and I was shocked by that the
as you know your assumption is these are
highly compensated individuals highly
intelligent individuals and they're
certainly planning and saving for the
future that just wasn't the case for the
most part so I would say to you that
historically during times of economic
pressure like this health care providers
always had a job always had stability
they weren't concerned about this
because you know their businesses would
be solid but as I spent a little time
thinking about this now a lot of the
specialists these highly compensated
individuals who are now not seeing
patients whether they chose to or the
patient's chose not to come in because
nobody's doing elective procedures is
unemployment's going up etc I think
they're worried you know if I was a
dermatologist right now I'd be worried
if I was a plastic surgeon right now I'd
be super worried and if you think that a
plastic surgeon isn't sitting on debt I
challenge that you know if I was a
dermatologist in a single practice right
now that isn't seeing patients doesn't
know when they're gonna see patients
again isn't getting fed through the
traditional system of primary care etc
I'd be concerned about like what is my
future look like how do I pay my debt
emergency room physicians if I was an
emergency room physician right now the
thing I'd be most concerned about is is
contracting kovat and not being able to
work there they're certainly going to
work and have have plenty of opportunity
but you know again most healthcare
providers are selfless and are doing
this this important work because they
just love humanity and people and and
they felt called to do this but I'm sure
they're concerned about getting sick
themselves and being taken out of the
game but I think for the first time
health care providers are probably
feeling feeling the economic stress of
this as well beyond just they
investment portfolio I'm talking about
their jobs being their jobs being
threatened and their livelihood being
threatened yeah keep going on that how
do you think this changes the healthcare
industry moving forward right so is
there consolidation among a lot of
individual practitioners do you see
these hospital systems expanding or
contracting like what happens from a
business perspective or a mechanism
perspective in these various healthcare
service providers yeah it's another
great question so I would expect that
coming out of this those that survive or
are on margin or have paused their
businesses
some throw their hands up and are fed up
and want to sell so a natural buyer of
peripheral or ancillary businesses is
going to be a healthcare establishment
or private equity that could see these
as distress assets and try to roll them
up so on the periphery you'll see that
happen from a hospital perspective those
that survive those that are robust
they'll pick off the community hospitals
that are under stress and and this is
another situation that they may throw
their hands up and and that's not a new
phenomenon I would say over the last 10
years community community-based
hospitals have been under stress of
closure so hospitals will try to pick
them off and consolidate them into
larger larger systems but I think you're
gonna see a period of consolidation
you'll see distressed assets being
picked up you'll see an opportunity for
venture capital to come in and roll
businesses up and expand them and then
you'll see some innovation so you'll see
telemedicine be adopted more
dramatically to tell you the truth if
you took me back to 2015 I would have
told you that telemedicine would have
been much more ingrained in totality in
the hospital system than it is today I
still think it's kind of like a boutique
thing it's not robust and and
disseminated so I see telemedicine
really growing out of this this event I
think at home testing is
another thing that you're going to see
really come out of this event we've
shown a complete breakdown of the supply
chain and logistics around just getting
getting tests for kovat 19 you'll see a
number of events around critical
equipment like masks and ventilators
that were out sourced even to foreign
countries be domesticated I think the
days of us waiting for another country
to supply us with masks like these
critical things are over this stuff's
gonna be built here in the United States
so that when we need it it's here and we
don't see supply chains break down yeah
one of the things that you'd mentioned
to me a couple of days ago I found
really fascinating was in times of
distress or emergency all of a sudden a
lot of the red tape and bureaucracy of
health care gets kind of pulled away and
so we've seen a couple of announcements
some are you know pretty straightforward
for people who have no healthcare
experience so something like a doctor a
certain type of doctor is only allowed
to participate in the state in which
they practice they can't practice across
state lines we saw an announcement
earlier this week verax's last week that
said hey that restriction will be
removed during this time of emergency do
you see kind of big regulatory changes
coming out of this or is it something
where it's more emergency measures and
then we'll go back to the old regime on
a regulation side yeah I actually think
again these are these are periods of
rapid innovation and those innovations
typically stick so you've seen a
dramatic one of the dramatic changes was
around hip HIPAA is is a rule around
patient privacy and it extends pretty
far it's important right we don't want
our protected healthcare information
shared in a way that that causes us
economic stress around our employer
something that they shouldn't or that
information being shared in a way we we
didn't we didn't want it to so these
rules are in place to protect patient
information and protect us
but they're they were pretty
far-reaching so HIPAA for example in
hi-tech those rules didn't allow me as a
health care provider to text you or to
phone you without you opting into that
and the only way I could communicate
with you from a treatment perspective
was through very complex patient portals
that were password protected even
telemedicine you couldn't use
traditional means videoconferencing like
we're using right now if you're using
zoom or Skype or or FaceTime
those weren't HIPAA and hi-tech approved
means for patient treatment so really
made telemedicine wonky and and just our
ability to communicate ineffective well
recently just a week or two ago and I
really applaud the Fed for doing this
they relaxed HIPAA and high tech
standards to allow for Skype and
FaceTime and patients to to communicate
with their providers with cell phones
and text messaging and email and all of
that is good because it allows for us to
segment those patients that don't need
to come in contact with the healthcare
establishment right now for routine
maintenance care refills of medication
just having questions those can be
answered and taken care of through
telemedicine and teleconferencing if you
go to my LinkedIn I wrote about you know
telemedicine has existed as long as
there were telephones really right that
was the first invention of telemedicine
but it's been just kind of slowed down
and made it effective through these laws
but really exciting times for for
patient care in regards to the relaxing
of HIPAA and high tech and as you as you
stated there's the relaxation of
medical licensure across state lines
there's just a lot of different things
that are happening right now to to help
expedite care and I applaud the the feds
for coming up with those those changes I
hope that we learn we're able to test
you know see what kind of you know
healthcare information fell through the
cracks if there were actually issues and
and maybe come out of it with a better
plan
yeah last question for you before I let
you get back to some real work is
there's a lot of talk right now
about potential cures things that can
kind of mitigate symptoms and so
obviously the famous ones now but that
chump tweeted is the hydroxychloroquine
or I think it's zip price Mison or
something these are things that have
shown in very small sample sizes some
level of impact but obviously have not
gone through the rigorous testing that
either the FDA or other regulatory
bodies would normally require how does
that testing environment change at a
time of emergency
meaning that you know whether it's these
drugs other drugs there's obviously a
sense of urgency here in some cases it
seems like it will still be months if
not you know a year plus what's kind of
your thoughts around that testing
environment and what we need to still
make sure things are safe but also kind
of expedite getting solutions for for
something that's obviously kind of
paralyzed the the economy yeah I think
you have to look at a comprehensive
strategy that the government's rolling
out right now and they're they're
looking at what was done in in Hong Kong
and in China and in other countries to
try to slow the progression of kovat 19
while they came up with a plan and I
think the United States has gone to that
rule that that playbook right so they've
said we're gonna do social distancing
physical distancing we're going to
shelter in place some segments of the
population and that's going to give us
time to take our pulse
we know that a vaccine is 12 to 18
shouts oh that's that's something we're
working on now but it's not going to be
readily deployable then they have to
look at treatments that have been used
so you mentioned hydroxychloroquine
which is like anti malaria drug it's
been used in Africa I'm not sure it's
used much anymore but it's from the
1940s and in combination with AZ through
my senoir zithromax you may know that as
a z-pack that's been shown to be
effective now those drugs exist they're
used for different purposes and what the
FDA has to do is add a use case so
that's what Trump I think has been
trying to say the FDA is rapidly working
to add you know a use for
hydroxychloroquine and ASA through mice
and potentially these drugs although
used for a long time for different for
different reasons they don't come
without risks both of those drugs cause
prolonged QT intervals so it's a cardiac
dysrhythmia that could be expressed with
those drugs so there are side effects
there's been limited experience and
deployment of that treatment but I think
over the next 15 to 30 days of us
slowing down people we're hoping to come
out of that with a treatment plan more
robust PPE potential you know vaccine
for the future because my fear is
actually the fall of this year you're
getting right back into a flu season and
we could have a resurgence or another
spike of kovat 19 and without a plan I
think that's the scariest thing for me I
think the American people just want to
plan with a plan then we can sort of get
back to normal you'll see maybe the
markets respond to a plan
and you know the treatment is really for
you know the moderate to severe cases
pomp it's not for the people who have
flu-like symptoms but are tolerating it
really that's just you know go home and
supportive care but it's those that are
needing respiratory support oxygen
potential admission and those that are
at high risk right I mean you're looking
at the mortality and morbidity goes up
pretty high actually or starts to go up
for those 40 or older then you have the
65 or older you know I was reading
you've got morbidity and mortality at
one point eight to three percent in that
older population you almost have nobody
under 19 dying of Cove at 19 you know
and the United States is I think third
on the list right now of of cases of
kovat 19 behind China and Italy in Italy
is number one in terms of fatality
associated with kovat 19 so I expect the
United States to rapidly move up the
list in in regards to cases end and
fatality associated with this
unfortunately it's just because just
massive country and we're stressing our
health care out to the max right now
yeah it's this weird combination of
health crisis the financial crisis
demographics working against many
countries right just older populations
etc so it's a you know it is a point in
history that will will be dissected I
think for for decades to come
unfortunately so we'll see how it plays
out yeah I really appreciate it one of
your tweets I think you you or you
continue to say stay safe and I
appreciate that you know I think
positive messages and support for a lot
of people who are sitting at home
they're scared and again for me whenever
I I'm concerned
I'm not sure of things organizing and
planning it kind of helps me feel better
about kind of where I am and again I'm
just waiting for a real plan to come
from the Fed and I know that will help
me out a whole bunch for sure we will
we'll put your Twitter account in the
comment section so that people can go
follow you on there got to get you yours
you're so close to thirty thousand we're
gonna get you there I get it yeah man
it's a it's a anyway I'm I'm one tenth
of the of your of your group of
followers on Twitter but I certainly
appreciate the time today and and this
is this is something I spent a lot of my
time on this healthcare space so you
know we have to succeed we have to
survive you know we have to take care of
each other and we'll get through all
this absolutely Joe just through your
Twitter account up on the on the screen
minutes they've got your back all right
thanks so much I miss want to get in the
future sounds good man talks in